I'm P Burgess and I'm the lead Foley
artist at Pinewood Studios we always
describe movie magic and they are the
secret life of movies while there is a
huge secret world behind the screen
obviously and Foley is one of them
basically my job is to recreate sound
effects that have happened in a film
very few sounds are fully recorded on
set and so there's a post-production
device put into place to help create
more sense to go on the film we perform
them we physically manipulate props in
order to make this end much more organic
rather than a track laid sound like a
door closing offered CD library or of
the Internet
it's like mimetics you have to you have
to kind of recreate the characters that
are on the screen and put them into your
performance often the original
recordings aren't very clear for the
spot effects which are the props the
things that the actors are picking up
and using or the footsteps like this it
could be a set so it's supposed to look
like a marble floor but it's just wood
so we'll then perform the footsteps
again or marble and make it sound like a
massive beautiful hole that's supposed
to be so as you can see we've got lots
of different surfaces I'm currently on
the concrete so we can add dust to this
and make it more gritty or we could add
we do the snow on here as well so we've
got a big sort of curtain load full of
industrial salt so we'll put that on
here we've got the earth pit here which
we can turn into marshes we turn into
the jungle loads of different things and
that all depends on what plants we put
in there so I've see at the moment we're
doing grass because we have grass in
there
and just behind it we've got the river
pit so we fill that up with water and we
would do the ocean or rivers or any sort
of water
and for Tarzan we actually filled it up
because they spend a lot of time running
in and out of the rivers in the jungle
so he put sort of a mud Bank on one side
of it so he could run down it and into
the water and then be absolutely covered
in mud a job will come in and we will
speak to the sound supervisor or the
post-production coordinator as soon as
there's a picture for us to work with
we'll get a copy of it and we'll begin
prepping the the shoot itself so someone
or many people in my team will go
through and plot out in the proto-tool
session every footstep that happens in
that whole film every cloth Russell
jewelry jangle every door that closes
hand down everything is planned so it
becomes just a huge map of sound doesn't
necessarily mean we'll shoot all of that
but it means that I know it's all being
identified and it's all there on the
screen and then as we begin our brief
what the team here is what we're doing
what the style approaches what you know
how we're going to approach this
particular film maybe only 10% or
sometimes as much as 60% of what we do
in this studio will be heard within the
final mix but it's about giving the
mixers as much ammunition sound wise as
possible to make a really buried
interesting soundtrack that does drive
the story so when recording Foley we
will break it into three little sections
feet moves and spots feet are pretty
self-explanatory the Foley artists will
select a shoe that matches that of the
characters and walk in time to the
character moving on the screen moves is
their cloth moves because actually
watching a film without any of that is
quite weird so they'll get a coat or a
bit of fabric that matches what the
character is wearing on screen
and just move in time with the
characters actions and spot effects are
anything that the actors or anything
interesting that happens on-screen that
obviously need to sound so a car door
closing Keys going into ignitions or
juggling anything any literally anything
that happens on screen we will try and
recreate so props generally come from
all over the place we all end up going
around second-hand shops and if there's
something that you pick up and it's got
a nice noise you might just buy it
anyway it's not so much the the object
as the the noise it makes and that's how
we we look at props just on the table
here if I reach over there's a perfect
example and although it does look like
the substance you would use it for this
is just a pillowcase full of corn flour
but it it has an amazing crushing sound
that we use for snow so if you add this
to a layer of snow you get that fresh
crushing kind of saying so that's one
example you just spend your life picking
things up and listening to them and
imagining what it could possibly be and
and now I have I have a an amazing sound
library in my head for what noise
objects make and how to manipulate them
it's really exciting when folio us we'll
go and find a prop and come out and
recreate exactly how you imagined
something to sound I find that really
exciting
[Music]
okay well please come in this is part of
my props tour this is the metal room we
need so many different props when we're
working on a film though I have to have
lots and lots of choices I try to keep
them in order otherwise they end up in
great big piles everywhere
lovely weapons against the wall here I
need several choices of weapons because
we don't want to keep the same you know
sword swinging in every every film we've
got a little costume department over
here for lots of different fabrics so we
can do moves and if there's a military
person we've got military uniforms we've
got trays as well so we use them as
shields for instance or just as trays
lovely resonating metal boxes because
there's so many times when for instance
if you're on a submarine we can't really
build up the space of a submarine and
you can hear my voice already resonating
against the metal oh no whoever the
submarine so we we would put that next
to the microphone and it would pick up
my movements and my boots and give it a
little of a mental resonance this is
scaffold stuff then we can make little
ratalie scaffolding noises we often use
those to add guns and things should we
go to the other room which is more of a
generic kind of prop as you can see it's
slightly different to the metal room in
as much as this is everything else that
isn't much you've already seen shoes
next door but we've got a much bigger
collection than the ones that are
actually in the theater again for choice
more than anything else
lots of boxes filled with shoes and
boots as we move along we kind of just
get more into communication books
telephones computers radios lovely
arrive hats along the top these are me
home exactly
noted by Band of Brothers moving along
we get a bit more generic into travel so
things like gloves wallets purses things
personal things that people would have
on them again you can imagine I don't
use the same players every time somebody
gets money out of the post I've got
about 50 purses 50 wallets and we just
mix it up all the time more of the
lovely Zoe my assistant shoes which she
has in here these they particularly like
ripped cloths things I can just tear up
and not ruin the cloth with but just
whip them for a way like I said bedding
for wigs
I've got lots of different types of wigs
and fair and things to make creature
noises broken china and broken tiles and
things because we don't always like to
buy absolutely brand-new and then break
it and because we're just making a smash
sound you can have actually have the
bits to begin with and then drop them
and it still makes the sound of a solid
object breaking little jewelry section
over here with a lovely vintage tail
which we adore and just about everything
in here is used for multiple purposes
everything we do is bespoke nothing is
repeated over and over again it would be
for me would be considered very lazy if
we did that kind of thing when we have
so many different choices to do things
from and the way I work as an artist is
to be as creative you know each day as a
few favorite projects of mine that we've
gotten to work on every year's one of
them that really stands out is ex
machina everything within that was
really interesting for being in the
theater to witness how it was recorded
because pretty much the whole building
is glass so what we did was would put up
all these big panes of glass around vast
Pete was performing some of the Foley
for it like any of the doors and the
footsteps in places it was all really
interesting to see and I think in the
end because there's only three people in
the whole of the film pretty much I
think it's really open to Foley and
stuff like that so I really enjoyed
witnessing one of that happen some of
the projects that I've worked on have
been transporting to Wonderwoman King
Arthur baby driver
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
all the principals are working to sync
with the right shoes and doing all the
rest of the things was completely thrown
out the window a baby driver because
every pair of shoes needed to sit in not
necessarily always into the world but
actually into the music sequence it
depended whether it's real world or
music we actually were wearing
headphones to make sure that we were
doing that and then altogether we'd
listen back and go actually the coffee
cups are slightly too hard or the shoes
aren't quite right because they're
poking through in slightly the wrong
frequency P and Zoe and Jason
particularly needed to pull themselves
away from thing can actually be
listening to the music and trying to
walk or run as close to the sink without
stepping outside of the music so we
don't like change shoes or Glenn and
Gemma would change something on the desk
because you don't want to interrupt the
music you just want to be there with it
[Music]
we were always thinking well is this
actually going to work with the music so
as a result we ended up using all
different things that we normally
wouldn't use in that film because it
complemented the music more and filled
in with the Sam supervisors sort of
vision for this job so that was we were
quite proud of the way that came out
like I said that was a very big sound
team collaborative effort with you know
big free last team and then I was
helping out it really does vary
depending on the project and depending
on how much post-production budget the
project has as to how long we can
actually spend in theatre for me
physically to perform up to perform a
film comfortably let's say a kitchen
sink drama that doesn't have a great
deal of CGI and it's no say in the war
it's a generic soundtrack eight days
would be comfortable for me four days
doing the feet maybe a day doing the
moves and then three or four days doing
the sound effects on a bigger project
with bigger budgets will tend to get a
longer time and maybe two weeks three
weeks on the final Harry Potter movies
there was five weeks there was so much
content in those films we might have
shot all of this media do we need all
this media maybe we don't actually maybe
we're out these ten sets of footsteps
maybe we only need three of them because
actually we're trying to pull focus on
the narrative that is happening over
here
so we don't a clutter the scene with
everything else because that could draw
attention or we just do just don't need
that sounds like actually it's actually
nicer to be simpler so we'll start
making those calls
editorially like creatively as we go
along generally in Foley we with notes
all without notes part of my joy is to
try and recreate everything whether it's
somebody's already sound designed a
dragon if I've got the time I might just
have a go anyway and offer up you know
something that they might not have
thought about all an addition to the
sound and then it's up to us it's up to
somebody else to decide by the
I don't know it's all really fun
everything about it I really enjoy doing
something that people might think is
quite mundane up to doing things like
car crashes and explosions I like
finding all the little details pete has
definitely been one of my biggest
inspirations like coming to work every
day with someone who absolutely lost a
job and is willing to help you with
anything is incredible I've had the best
tutor but also the whole team like
everybody is so passionate and driven
about what we do that we're all working
together it's like yeah we've got this
and we can do it and look at what we've
just made isn't it amazing
that's great I think the things I enjoy
most is is just that instant creativity
that we that we we have to employ I mean
there is no training course that you can
go to and do for Foley's it's really
about self-expression and about building
of a library within your head and a
dexterity with objects so it's it's it's
just a very interesting crazy kind of
kind of job
[Music]